Marlon how were you able to deal with
creating different point of views like
frog world in human world like how did
you create that I was the head of
effects for folks who are interested in
animation but uh okay and I just I did
also the co head of effects of movie
frozen yes yes but I am and frozen to
come into it thing I have to say on a
person if I can if I can digress for a
minute because I was a hand-drawn
animator works I started at Disney on
Lion King and this is and were and and I
and I was I was proud to it made the
transition from hand-drawn into a
digital animator and so and and I'll be
frank weird this is a this is a safe
room I was one of the few hand-drawn
folks in the building and one of the few
brothers in the building at the time and
so when they who we launched into
princess in the frog it was like getting
the old band back together in a lot of
ways right yeah cool man cobwebs of who
knows where and there's a whole bunch of
folks still I'll glimmer in this room
they came and worked on the film with us
and then a whole bunch of this beautiful
voice talent to this day the only folks
who ever came to one of our damn rat
parties thank you all because I think
usually it's kind of like you're invited
to the wrap party well they'll be
pressed there no okay see you at the
premiere everybody on that into the room
was there because that's how much
consistent the frog meant three but yeah
it was beautiful but to get to your
question about scale I mean it was it
was a bit of a challenge because you
know we had human size characters and
then our characters drink down a little
frog size and how do we actually support
how do we do splashes to actually you
know make help kind of support the fact
that these guys are shrunk down and the
idea of actually doing big floppy
splashes we actually kind of tried in a
little cheaper didn't look like nice
disney water
so we actually just sped them up you
know we actually kind of eventually put
all the richness we would do for a big
splash into a little splash for Tiana
and Naveen but um but it was it was a
lot of fun and it was that it was a
delight doing all the other various
transitions turning Tiana into a frog
and for frog Tiana into human Tiana and
it was a beautiful one of my favorite
book moments in the film County Meath
Leighton the storytelling part and it's
late in the film or facili a shows fraud
Tiana what her life could be and he
turns her back into Tiana is one of the
few times kind of in the middle of the
film where she's human Tiana again and
some of the effects we created to turn
her back into a human and to actually
show her what her life could be was some
of the coolest moments in the film for
me so I was really fun
[Applause]